this guy is out of control hey everyone
I'm Abby sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we'll be taking a look
at Paul celadino AKA carnivore MD but
first let me tell you about my sponsor
seed and take you along with me on my
nighttime routine so when it's time to
unwind for bed I put my phone onto
nighttime mode and I try to avoid any
screens or blue light instead I try to
read a book or like a low commitment
magazine until my eyes start to get
tired then I will of course wash my face
and put on my face cream or oil or
whatever brush my teeth and then I'll
take my medications supplements and my
symbiotic so I use seeds ds01 daily
symbiotic I like seeds ds01 because you
get both a pre and a probiotic that
contains 24 clinically and
scientifically studied probiotic strains
and a plant-based non-fermenting
Prebiotic the way they've engineered
their two in one capsule ensures a
hundred percent delivery of the
probiotic to your colon so that you'll
really reap the benefits seedst01
supports Beyond gut health think things
like heart health skin Health gut immune
function and so much more most
probiotics actually end up dying in your
stomach acid so if you've taken a
probiotic before and felt no difference
it's likely because it just wasn't
surviving the harsh environments of our
GI tract but seed is different in this
regard I also really like that they're
sustainably delivered every month so you
get a refillable glass jar with your
first purchase and the monthly refills
are delivered in compostable
biodegradable and recyclable packaging
so if you want to check out seed
yourself you can get 50 off of your
first month's supply of seeds ds-01
daily symbiotic by clicking the link in
the description and using my code Abby
at checkout and you can pause the screen
or look at my description to check out
my disclaimer including a trigger
warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating so as always please feel free to
skip this video If it's not supportive
to your journey and if you are not
already subscribed hit that subscribe
button and follow me over on Tick Tock
and Instagram at Abby's kitchen so you
may recognize our friend Paul as that
shirtless dude on Tick Tock wandering
around the grocery aisles and making you
fear legitimately every ingredient in
your favorite foods look at me I'm
shaking in my little space boots you
know the guy I called out right here all
of your chips
all of these chips seed oils seed oils
can you avoid this well good thing you
don't actually have to otherwise you may
have seen them on YouTube or heard him
on a random podcast claiming that a
heavy meat diet can reverse chronic
disease because vegetables are in his
words
now before I put Paul's carnivore claims
to the test let's first take a we look
at what he eats in a day I'm going to
show you guys what I eat and when I eat
throughout the day it's 6 a.m about to
get a surfing this is my breakfast I'm
breaking the overnight fast it's small a
little bit of goat's milk kefir mango
and a shot of honey and off to serve so
I gotta say this actually caught me by
surprise I mean this morning meal
provides a solid 80 grams of
carbohydrates with not a rash or a bacon
sausage or an egg inside but according
to Paul he initially started on a strict
meat only carnivore diet but experienced
electrolyte imbalances causing severe
heart palpitations and muscle cramps
which I assume were not so fun I'm
surprised a medical doctor wouldn't have
predicted that outcome come ahead of
time but I'm definitely glad he figured
it out but sodium and potassium
imbalances are actually quite common in
restrictive diets like this the body
needs a minimum of 500 milligrams of
sodium per day just to function and you
would need a minimum of two pounds of
meat a day just to squeak by and this is
the bare minimum we're talking so most
would need a lot more to actually feel
good and Thrive so it absolutely makes
sense that he would feel better starting
his day with some solid Easy Fuel he
also claims that reintroducing carbs has
helped to improve his sleep mood and
exercise performance again that makes
total sense since carbs help to boost
tryptophan and serotonin in the brain
which are involved in sleep and mood he
also seems like a pretty active guy and
most research suggests that we ideally
want to aim for one to four grams of
carbs per kilogram of body weight as a
pre-workout with more intense activity
needing the upper end of that range so
this 80 gram pre-surf session breakfast
is definitely on point back from surfing
and breakfast
will be on there raw heart raw liver and
desiccated testicle whole package from
heart and soil supplements a mango part
of a pineapple cut up glyphosate free
honey and goat's milk kefir I'm gonna
eat all of this for breakfast for real
and then I'll show you guys dinner
around 3 30 or 4 P.M today I mean I'm
not one to yuck someone's yum but the
combo of beef heart and mango is
definitely a new one for me but I am
still kind of relieved to see it now
this meal alone provides almost 2 000
calories which is a solid serving that
maybe is necessitated by the fact that
he also practices intermittent fasting
and he has a Shoring eating window now
given how much satiating fat and protein
there is in meat hitting your calorie
needs in just a few meals is probably a
pretty huge feat and that rhyme by the
way like I would assume that feels like
you're in a Hot Dog Eating competition
every day legs on that stage and know
Sonia earlier but so I do think it's
smart to supplement with some faster
digesting carbs and it's also nice to
see a bit more micronutrients
antioxidant diversity probiotics and a
little fiber here which is definitely a
step up from a lot of the other
carnivores that we've reviewed here and
because of these additions Paul's
actually getting a solid amount of
potassium vitamin C A and calcium plus
almost 30 grams of fiber which are key
nutrients that most carnivores tend to
miss so it does seem like he's done his
homework and figured out the easiest way
to meet his needs my dinner it's the
same as my breakfast I never get sick of
this meat organs fruit honey raw dairy
it's 4 P.M I've been eating since 6am
I'm going to finish this meal by 5 PM
that's a 13 hour fast and 11 hour eating
window this is how I do it every day now
dinner is apparently pretty much the
exact same meal and ends by around 4 P.M
so we're basically getting Mega doses of
protein in two large sittings per day
the problem with this is that we know
the body can only utilize so much
protein for muscle protein synthesis per
sitting so usually in the neighborhood
of 20 to 40 grams depending on your body
size and muscle capacity it's still good
energy but most people would have better
uptake and efficiency spreading that
protein over several more meals the
other challenge with this diet is that
it provides three times the saturated
fat maximum recommended by Major
authorities now as I discussed in my
video right here the evidence on
saturated fats is very controversial and
mixed yet we do know that high intakes
of saturated fat from red meat
specifically increases the production of
trimethylamyline and oxide which is
associated with an increased risk of
heart disease so while we still need
more conclusive evidence on the impact
of saturated fats as a whole I do think
it's best that we err on the side of
caution on the red meat front and this
isn't even touching on the environmental
impacts which is a reason enough to cut
back or avoid now with all that said
let's move on to to some of the common
claims that Paul makes about the
carnivore diet claim number one
vegetables are toxic why would you eat
plant leaves and stems and roots and
seeds these are the most highly defended
parts of plants they put defense
chemicals in those parts of plants
things like oxalates lectins saponins
digestive enzyme Inhibitors like tannins
these are going to mess up your
digestion and your hormones generally
make you feel horrible they're going to
make you fart a lot too you guys know
what I like I like the least toxic plant
Foods things like fruit and the most
nutritious Foods on the planet animal
meat and organs so this is a super
strange Health concern in my opinion
especially for this guy you want to know
what else has tannins bananas and
mangoes both of which appear to be a
staple in Paul's diet as he claims to
consume two to three mangoes and five to
six bananas every day some fruits like
kiwis raspberries and oranges also
contain oxalates so it's argument that
fruits are the least toxic plant food
Foods because they don't contain these
defense chemicals
doesn't really Stack Up and is totally
contradictory in his case saponins and
lectins on the other hand are primarily
contained in things like legumes greens
and some vegetables but are these
compounds really a cause for concern
well it's true that anti-nutrients in
some plant-based foods do in fact reduce
the absorption of some vitamins and
minerals but research suggests that
anti-nutrients are really not a major
threat to our health for example when it
comes to lectins the biggest culprit is
raw uncooked beans and that threat is
significantly diminished simply by
cooking I'm not sure about you but I
don't recall the last time that I had a
raw dried kidney bean salad so that
argument kind of always feels like a bit
of a stretch as for tannins the major
concern here is that they may inhibit
iron absorption but research suggests
that the amounts present in Foods aren't
really high enough to significantly
impact iron absorption in folks with
healthy iron levels and those with iron
deficiency May simply want to avoid
consuming tannins alongside their
iron-rich foods or supplements and then
there's oxalates which we know can
impact the absorption of calcium however
resets suggests that the general
population can safely consume oxalates
with no issues and a low oxalate diet
would only be indicated for folks who
are prone to developing kidney stones
not to mention oxalate content can also
be effectively reduced through cooking
lastly even though saponins are
considered natural pesticides to ward
off Predators we don't see the same risk
for humans through food more importantly
than debunking these anti-veg myths is
to reinforce what you're missing out on
if you cut them out for example tannins
are actually a rich source of
antioxidants and contain
anti-inflammatory properties saponins
contain cholesterol lowering Properties
or high in antioxidants reduce
inflammation and may even inhibit cancer
cell growth foods rich in oxalates are
also often a good source of vitamin C
which actually helps to boost the
absorption of iron and don't forget that
plant foods are rich in fiber so
remember we don't eat nutrients we eat
food and food is a lot more than the sum
of its parts when we focus on what
components we need to cut out we miss
the forest from the trees but anyway I
also need to point out that the study he
cited to support all of his claims
looked at the concentration of unique
plant-based compounds from broccoli and
kale and its potential to negatively
impact the thyroid and even this study
that Paul himself cited concluded that
regular consumption of these vegetables
is unlikely to cause any adverse effect
so that's kind of some disappointing
critical analysis from a healthcare
professional like an MD
sad which brings me to claim number two
you apparently do not need vegetables
for a healthy gut there is no indication
that fiber is beneficial for the gut in
terms of inflammation or Alpha diversity
people are just wrong so the study that
Paul cites here found that there was no
change in the gut microbiome diversity
with increased fiber intake but
researchers did find an increase with
fermented foods however this conclusion
does not suggest that fiber from
vegetables is not beneficial for a
healthy gut or that it does not play a
role in gut diversity we have extensive
research showing that fiber supports
regularity and even helps to feed the
gut bacteria by providing a source of
prebiotics fiber also helps to lower
cholesterol and regulate blood sugar
levels also we can make a declarative
conclusion from one study alone when the
larger body of research suggests
otherwise for example two large studies
found that gut microbiome diversity was
significantly associated with fiber
intake another intervention study found
that the composition of the gut
microbiome Changed by eight percent
after following a high fiber diet for
just two weeks we do tend to see the
greatest increase in microbiome
diversity when we're going going from a
low fiber diet to a high fiber diet
whereas folks who regularly consume a
fiber anyways are able to more or less
maintain their gut diversity likely
explaining the unimpressive results in
the study that Paul cited lastly this
brings us to claim number three the
carnivore diet is anti-inflammatory if
you listen to the mainstream media
they'll tell you the meat is
inflammatory
nothing could be further from the truth
most people realize that foods like
cookies and brownies with seed oils and
processed sugars are inflammatory this
is true but did you know that even bread
wheat can be inflammatory gluten
contains lectins which will disrupt the
tight junctions of your gut and cause
leaky gut that will activate your immune
system and that is essentially what
inflammation is also even fewer people
realize that plant leaves and vegetables
the root stems leaves and seeds of
plants contain defense chemicals which
can also trigger your immune system and
lead to inflammation and the triggering
of autoimmune conditions uh my friend
it's not the media that tells us this
it's extensive scientific evidence so to
give you just a few examples of the
anti-inflammatory properties of
vegetables broccoli is rich in the
antioxidant sulforaphane which has been
shown to reduce inflammatory markers
like cytokines and nuclear Factor Cap B
tomatoes are rich in lycopene which has
been shown to reduce inflammation
cardiovascular risk factors and also
cancer mortality bell peppers contain
antioxidants like vitamin C and corcorin
which have likewise been shown to have
anti-inflammatory effects and these
three random vegetables are just the tip
of the iceberg when it comes to the
anti-inflammatory effects of plant-based
Foods on the other hand we also got
research showing that a high red meat
intake is significantly associated with
higher concentrations of inflammatory
markers like C-reactive protein and it's
interesting that he brought up bread
because we actually do have research
showing that high consumption of whole
grain bread was actually related to
lower levels of inflammation whereas
High consumption of red meat was
likewise associated with higher levels
of inflammation however the majority of
the research does suggest that the
inflammatory effects of red meat is more
prevalent in folks with higher body fat
but regardless even if you have a low
body fat and can consumer diet rich in
red meat there are still considerable
health risks for example as I mentioned
earlier High intakes of red meat
increase with the production of
trimethylamyline and oxide or tmao which
is in the gut and is associated with a
higher risk of cardiovascular disease
it's also associated with increased
risks of colorectal breast and prostate
cancer and can strain our kidneys and
increase calcium loss plus High intakes
of meat prepared via dry heat cooking
methods like grilling and frying can
increase the consumption of advanced
glycation end products also known as
ages and we also know that high intakes
of Ages can increase oxidative stress
and inflammation in the body on the
other hand plant-based foods like fruits
vegetables legumes and whole grains are
actually the lowest sources of dietary
ages and research has even shown that a
diet high in antioxidant rich foods like
fruits and vegetables helps to mitigate
the effects of Ages on the body so
technically you can argue that Paul's
diet isn't terribly pro-inflammatory but
that's only because he includes large
quantities of fruit in his diet to kind
of balance out the meat so in conclusion
I have to throw Paul a bone because his
animal-based diet is certainly not the
worst that I've seen in the arena of
carnivorism but it's his content that
Riles me the [ __ ] up his videos are Rife
with outlandish claims that are
supported by cherry-picked inconsistent
research that's at odds with the
literature at large and it's honestly
disappointing to see a medical doctor
demonize something as obviously
nutritious as vegetables so if you take
anything away from this is to be careful
whose nutrition advice you trust online
not all professionals are evidence-based
and not all science is great science I
hope my content helps you think more
critically whenever you can so on that
note that's all that I have for you guys
today if you like this this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on who or what you'd like
to see me review next subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]